you feel so trapped and alone it's the
responsibility of the doctors to
you know not not force that in any way
upon children
clara was just 15 when she felt
something wasn't right
not knowing where to turn she went to a
gender identity clinic
and started treatment including surgery
to become
quincy eight years on she wants to
transition
back to being a woman and is suing the
nhs
it's such a serious process to go down
and it's so experimental because
you know doctors don't even know you
know the outcomes of a lot of these
treatments that are given out i should
have been you know told to wait and and
not affirmed
in my gender identity i was claiming to
have and
yeah just given intensive therapy
basically to
investigate the feelings i was having to
try and you know
figure out how i got to that stage kira
was already taking the clinic she was
treated at to court
and now she's going further she believes
she was steered down a medical pathway
and wants clinicians to do more to
explore the reasons
why a young person is changing their
gender before they're treated kira says
the counselling
she received here should have
prioritized her biological sex in the
same way it did her gender identity
but the tavistock center say that they
provide a thoughtful and measured
service and as they put it their
dedicated staff have the best interests
of their patients at heart nhs england
say they offer a range of evidence-based
services including counselling
hormone therapy and lifelong monitoring
of physical and mental health to ensure
people
considering transition are supported in
a safe and appropriate manner
hi alex hi lisa how are you and it is
true that some have a very different
experience
alex was 13 when he began treatment to
reassign his gender
he believes the tavistock clinic saved
his life
there were just so many times when you
just
they were like are you sure you want to
do this and then there were so many
consent forms and
questions and there were just so many
points where you could be like
no i'd say it's really thorough
and and that you know if this system's
not working properly
you know there's the danger that people
resort to
private treatments and you know
kind of go down some avenues that aren't
monitored and are kind of unregulated so
ironically if you make it harder then
people are just going to
inject themselves with anything and it
will just make everything worse
these aren't choices that are taken
lightly for both alex
and kira these were very personal
decisions they made as children
but with very different outcomes ali
fortescue sky news